men who have a dad bod type physique  which would be a higher deposits of gut  fat they are judged by both men and  women as being better fathers both men  and women look at a guy who has a dad  bod  and they see somebody who has fewer  doors open to him where he could spend  calories that he gets so if you have  some guy that's good looking and in  really great shape and that man has a  wife and or a partner ancestrally and a  couple of kids he could spend any energy  that he wants on them but he might also  be able to spend his energy chasing some  other women around because he is  sufficiently attractive to bring them in  so men that have Dad bods are perceived  as being better fathers mostly because  they have fewer options open to them  that they could stray from their family  with